TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER
WITH US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
>> YOU BETTER.
>> Tucker: FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS, LAURA MORRIS HAS BEEN A
TEACHER IN VIRGINIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
UNTIL TUESDAY.
TUESDAY SHE QUIT HER JOB IN
FRONT OF THE SCHOOL BOARD.
WHY DID SHE DO THAT?
SHE EXPLAINED.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> I WAS TOLD IN ONE OF MY
SO-CALLED EQUITY TRAININGS ABOUT
WHITE CHRISTIAN ABLE-BODIED
FEMALES CURRENTLY HAVE THE POWER
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND THAT, "THIS
HAS TO CHANGE."
CLEARLY, YOU'VE MADE YOUR POINT.
YOU KNOW LONGER VALUE ME OR MANY
OTHER TEACHERS YOU'VE EMPLOYED
IN THIS COUNTY.
SINCE MY CONTRACT OUTLINES THE
POWER THAT YOU HAVE OVER MY
EMPLOYMENT IN LOUDOUN COUNTY
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, I FOUND IT
NECESSARY TO RESIGN IN FRONT OF
YOU.
SCHOOL BOARD, I QUIT.
I QUIT YOUR POLICIES.
I QUIT YOUR TRAINING.
I QUIT BEING A COG IN THE
MACHINE THAT TELLS ME TO PUSH
HIGHLY POLITICIZED AGENDAS ON
OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CONSTITUENTS, THIS CHILDREN.
I WILL FIND EMPLOYMENT
ELSEWHERE.
I ENCOURAGE ALL PARENTS AND
STAFFS IN THIS COUNTRY TO FLEET
OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
>> Tucker: LAURA MORRIS IS THE
TEACHER.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THERE IS SOMETHING REALLY MOVING
ABOUT THE END OF THE VIDEO.
TAKING FROM YOUR EMOTION THAT
YOU DID NOT WANT TO QUIT.
WHY DID YOU QUIT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, TUCKER,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
ME TO YOUR SHOW.
CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT AN HONOR
THIS IS AND TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION, YES, IT WAS VERY
EMOTIONAL AND VERY HARD DECISION
TO COME TO COMMIT IT WAS NOT
TAKEN LIGHTLY UP YOUR PEOPLE ASK
WHY I CHOSE TO DO IN THAT MANNER
AND THE TRUTH IS I JUST KNEW
THAT ALL I WAS LEAVING BEHIND,
THE SACRIFICE AND THE DECISION
WAS GREAT FOR ME.
THE SACRIFICE BEING MY STUDENTS,
I WAS NOT GOING TO SEE MORE OR
THE STAFF THAT I WORK WITH, THAT
I WASN'T GOING TO SEE EVERY DAY
ANYMORE, SO I WANTED THEM TO SEE
WHY I WAS LEAVING AND WITH MY
NAIVETE I DID NOT IMAGINE OTHER
PEOPLE WOULD SEE IT.
I GUESS I KNEW THAT WOULD
HAPPEN, BUT I WASN'T THINKING
BEYOND THAT NIGHT.
SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED OUT OF THAT
AS A RESULT, JUST THE OUTREACH,
IT HAS BEEN UNLIKE WHAT I WOULD
EVER IMAGINE.
IT'S BEEN A LIFE-CHANGING
EXPERIENCE AND I'M HONORED AND
HUMBLED BY IT ALL.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE SO FEW
BRAVE PEOPLE THAT WHEN YOU SEE
ONE THAT STICKS WITH YOU, AND
YOU ARE ONE BIT WHAT EFFECT DO
YOU THINK ALL OF THIS IS HAVING
ON THE KIDS IN SCHOOLS?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU MENTIONED BRAVE
AND IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE I CAN
DESCRIBE ME BECAUSE THIS IS ALL
DONE BY THE GRACE OF GOD, THE
PROVISION I'VE HAD SINCE DOING
WHAT I DID, JUST THE COURAGE TO
GET UP AND DO IT COMES FROM MY
WALK WITH THE LORD AND I
RECEIVED SO MANY TEXTS, SO MANY
EMAILS FROM STUDENTS, FAMILIES
OF STUDENTS THAT I'VE TAUGHT IN
THE PAST AND THEY ARE JUST, THEY
ARE JUST SO HAPPY FOR ME THAT I
MADE THE DECISION THAT I DID
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT IT WAS
WHAT WAS RIGHT FOR ME AND THEY
ARE STILL WITH ME.
THERE'S SO MUCH SUPPORT.
THEY ARE ALL JUST LETTING ME
KNOW THAT WE HAVE YOUR BACK, WE
LOVE YOU, STUDENTS LOVE YOU,
IT'S JUST BEEN WONDERFUL.
>> Tucker: TEACHING KIDS THAT
SOME RACES ARE BETTER THAN
OTHERS IS SO IMMORAL THAT I
WONDER IF WILL MORE TEACHERS
QUIT BEFORE THEY TEACH THAT?
>> ONE OF THE EMAILS I RECEIVED
FROM ANOTHER STATE, IT'S PHILIP
FROM CONNECTICUT, IT'S BEEN SAID
THAT ONE CANDLE CAN ONLY LIKE A
THOUSAND OTHERS WITHOUT
DIMINISHING ITS OWN ILLUMINATION
AND HE SAID, YOU ARE THAT
CANDLE.
I WAS SO MOVED BY THOSE WORDS
BECAUSE I NEVER THOUGHT OF
MYSELF IN THAT POSITION, NEVER
FELT LIKE -- IN FACT, I FEEL
LIKE THE BLESSING OF GOD POURING
DOWN FOR ME WHICH IS HAPPY THAT
I'M SO EXCITED WHAT I DID AND
WHAT I SAID MIGHT SPARK OTHERS,
ELIMINATE IN OTHERS THE DESIRE
TO PUT SOME ACTION TO THEIR
WORDS.
THERE'S A LOT OF WARS GOING ON
IN COUNTY, PEOPLE UPSET ON BOTH
SIDES, AND I'M JUST NOTICING
MORE AND MORE THAT DOESN'T SEEM
TO BE CHANGING THINGS.
BUT IF PEOPLE DO SOMETHING BOLD,
WHEN PEOPLE PUT ACTION TO THEIR
WORDS, ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER THAN
WORDS AND THAT SEEMS TO BE
CAPTIVATING PEOPLE.
SO I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHAT OTHER
ACTIONS PEOPLE MIGHT BE TAKING.
>> I HOPE OTHERS CONCLUDE THEY
CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN THIS